look i don't see what the big deal is so
as you might have heard a lawyer
appeared in court
as a cat let's watch ponton i believe
you have a
filter turned on in the video settings
yeah you think i think that's a filter
you might want to uh we're trying to
we're can you hear me judge i can hear
you i think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
god
we've all been there with technical
difficulties that you can't fix i'm
prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
that's got to be one for the ages i'm
here live i'm not a cat look the overall
lesson here is that things go wrong in
court
all the time and the judge says that
this lawyer handled it with grace and
composure and
you just gotta roll with the punches
especially in this pandemic world you've
gotta deal with things like video
conferencing but the other lesson is if
you're going to have a video conference
with the judge
make sure that a you're wearing pants
and b you're not a cat
hashtag not legal advice but this is
advice subscribe or i'll see you in
court